thank you
all right it being 8 31 now we're gonna
open this uh work session on hb107
um for the record this is my first time
seeing a subcommittee meeting let alone
attending one or being a chair of one so
bear with me as we go through this here
um
I understand it's relatively informal
um obviously we want people speaking one
of the time but
um
I guess the first one would be to have
the response for the Bill maybe
discuss we've heard your testimony
already so if you want to if you have
anything new to add or you want to
emphasize some things and then maybe
take some questions and we could discuss
your proposal
thank thank you Mr chairman
um members of the subcommittee I
appreciate the opportunity to be here
and I'm here to work with you answer any
questions uh engage in any
um discussion that that we may want to
have
um I'm going to lead with my chin and
say we don't want to let the perfect be
the enemy of the good
the fact of the matter is it's my
opinion that we have a loophole in
existing RSA and two cases have been
brought forth unfortunately both from
from the town that I live in and a
constituent has asked me to to file
legislation to to close this loophole
and while I appreciate you know the need
to keep opportunities open for people
that are on the registered sex offender
list it's my opinion that they should
not be employing be managing or be the
direct supervisor or left alone to work
one-on-one with minor children that puts
both parties both the registered sex
offender and the minor child in
potential Jeopardy and so it's in our
best interest to protect both of those
groups I I know there was a lot of
questions
around
um you know primarily with miners part
of the the bill as written and I I don't
think I was very clear on what the
intent there was and so I'd like to
clarify uh what the intent is there so
maybe we can find some uh language that
we can all agree on uh to to clean that
up so when we see that language
what the what the sponsor of the bill
myself and what the constituent is
asking for this this goes to things like
schools
daycares
after school
um
programs
that you might you might have right
where where kids go after school Boys
and Girls Clubs thing things like that
it it's not meant or intended
to prohibit somebody working as a clerk
at the corner store that's that's not
you know yeah technically are you
providing a service to minors yeah you
know you're selling them whatever
they're coming in to buy bread milk
candy whatever it is but you're not
you're not the customer is not an
employee right so it's it's the it's
this this employer employee relationship
link this possibility that the employer
the manager the supervisor or working
directly with children that are
registered sex offenders that's the link
we want to break that's the firewall
that we want to reinforce
so you know can can somebody work at a
local grocery store you know as a bagger
or whatever yeah absolutely because it's
it's a it's a it's a customer right and
those discussions we were having it was
it was it was a customer coming in now
you can say well an after-school program
the kid is the customer because the
parents are paying to send the kid and
and and that is right right but that the
job there is actually supervising
children right they show up after school
and if you're working there you're
supervising you're managing you're
around those children and that's the
that's the link that we're trying to
break that's the intent of the law I'm
certainly hoping
that we can come to some
mutual language that will reinforce that
firewall the challenge that I have is
most of the proposed amendments that
have been brought forth
um by others
in my reading of those it simply adds
language but is ineffectual at building
the firewall that we're looking to build
that the language ends up being so loose
to make it easier for registered sex
offenders to find employment that it
doesn't close the loophole and if we're
just going to change language but the
loophole remains open then then really
we're just we're wasting our time we're
spinning our wheels in the in the mud
the idea is to put this firewall up to
close this loophole
I'll take any questions any anybody may
have
representative Muse
I I just want to say that um this
particular particular crime is
um just about the worst thing you can do
to a person next to murder because the
the child uh who's the victim
is never really the same again that
person is effectively gone
um
but I I do thought I do I I did think
that in his node representative Lynn
made a good point
um in that one of the things that we
have to balance is the need to minimize
the risk to children with the fact that
um we can't create something over that's
so overbroad that it would totally
prohibit many types of employment for
people
who may be trying to to to rehabilitate
so one thing
one thing I would I would suggest is to
and I know this may sound a little
strange in the context of of this
hearing but to take an approach
that you know kind of from the gun
violence prevention handbook which
essentially is
um
we know that nothing that we can do in
statute will totally eliminate or
prevent
these things from happening but there
are things that we can do to minimize
the risk so an approach that we could
take is
are there some things that we can do to
the statute that will further reduce the
risk of this happening to Children
um and and my concern with with your
need to to almost totally close the
window is is I don't think that that we
can do that or it would be
constitutional necessarily for us to do
that but but looking at the statutes of
other states it does look like there are
some things that other states uh are
doing
um that perhaps we could adopt here in
New Hampshire too so the the idea
you know well it would be wonderful to
close the window completely so that
these incidents never happen again
um as you say if if we if we don't throw
out the good and search is the perfect
what we can do is close that window to a
point where it's it's harder for uh for
these types of offenses to happen than
Perhaps it is now and and that's that's
the approach I I'd kind of like to see
us take
thank you representative if I could
respond if that's okay and then I'll
take any question you have thank you
representative I I appreciate um your
remarks and and I I don't uh on the face
of it I don't disagree with any of it
for sure I I think I think we have a lot
of common ground
um the one thing I have to say is I
can't comment on what the representative
submitted to the committee or the
subcommittee is I wasn't put on copy on
any of that
um so I don't I don't have those
materials so the representative you
spoke to I I've I've never received
copies of those so I can't really speak
to what um what what those proposals are
other than things that I saw last
session
sorry if I didn't
think I
but that's I mean it is that's exactly
as you can see that's it even has the
date from from uh
from last time so that that's the that's
the same uh thing
in the last session
thank you representative I I appreciate
it
if I may and this is where I was I had a
hang up with and uh
this is how I interpret this and I
understand your intent however down the
road when this becomes law
that intent is going to be interpreted
by a judge and they may interpret it
differently
the first part is employment in business
providing Direct Services to minor or
direct supervision the oversight of
minors
if you put the emphasis on employment
and leave business out of it
it makes more sense as to what your
intent is but if I was to put the
emphasis on business
that's where people
are thinking that any business that
provides a direct service to miners you
couldn't work at which would mean
McDonald's or a movie theater or
convenience store and I understand it's
not your intent
but if I put the emphasis on business
that's how I interpret that is that any
business so we will be limiting work
virtually anywhere
so I think that's the hang up yeah so um
if if striking if striking a word
um
gets you to where you need to be namely
you know taking the reference of
business out and making an appointment
only so well let me just back up a
little bit
I'm not good at thinking on my feet so
you bear with me
the burden should be in my opinion on
the employee if the burden should be on
the registered sex offender they're the
ones that you know have have committed a
crime Tried by a jury of their peers
found to be guilty and and are taking
the punishment that the society Doles
out for that
the the burden I I believe should be on
that person they're the ones that need
to take responsibility and full
responsibility
um for the consequences of their
previous actions and and I agree so
there was actually language other
language in the original bill that was
um stripped out during a working session
that we had last year so we had an
extensive working session
um last year I think representative
Manus um were you part of that last year
or no
yeah so so you know we we we had we had
State Police we had attorney general we
had um
um Department of Justice maybe that's
part of Attorney General
um we had you know victims right
Advocates ACLU and um registered sex
offender Advocates and and we all sort
of agreed on the language and that was
the languages put in front of you I'm
not a you know I'm not opposed to
further
um changing the the other thing that
that I'll bring up is during that work
committee it was not I'm not the guy
that stripped out the list of examples
it was actually the groups that came
before us that recommended stripping out
that language
um
so that it doesn't become too narrow by
way of examples so
um personally I think I think it's a
cleaner RSA without the list of examples
um but I mean if that's if that's what
it takes to get over the hurdle to leave
that language in you know I I would
suppose that I'm I'm fine with that but
that language is stripped out at the
request of others that came to the
working session the previous year
yeah I think a lot of what I was going
to say has already been kind of brought
up in this situation I think you know in
the beginning you know when we heard
this in the first place the it was the
language it was too broad and then how
is this going to be interpreted and then
also I think how is the owners who is
the owner that's going to be on is it
going to be on the employer and the
employee or the employee and then how is
that defined but so is this proposed
amendment actually for is this what
you're you're trying to use now or is
this just for reference of what was
submitted last year
thank you representative for the
question I appreciate it this is this is
not my Amendment so I I brought the bill
um forward again this year and what I
brought forward this year is what had
been agreed to and approved out of
committee out of a work group and out of
the committee last year this was a floor
amendment that was brought forth
um to house session uh last year in when
we were meeting in in Manchester in the
function of Manchester so so the the
person that I think can speak
um best to to this proposed change would
be the representative behind me to my
right because it's it's his Amendment
sounds good
thank you and this and this floor
amendment was voted down for what it's
worth um last year during session okay I
think
I think OJ was saying clarifying this
and saying that that provides services
exclusively or predominantly to minors
really clarifies the language a bit so I
I know it was voted down last year so
well I like that so it's it's not parts
right when you're voting on the floor
you can't say well I like paragraph one
but I don't like paragraph three okay I
I don't disagree that line I like that
language too
um and it's you know the the list I
again I don't I don't care the the
advice was to get rid of the list to
make it less confusing if we want to put
the list back in because that's what's
in current RSA that's you know that
that's fine too
um so yeah I I I think I think I I agree
with where your where your stance is at
okay thank you thank you Barbara Bolden
on the topic of the list I think that
that I understand that the sponsor wants
to be flexible
um and kind of work with the concerns of
the committee
but
um I think that initially like in the
initial hearing
um the sponsor
testimony another testimony kind of
helped me understand that the list was
the problem and lists in legislation can
be problems
um because when
when that day comes that someone's in
front of a judge the judge says well
what did the legislature intend and
they'll take into consideration
everything that was discussed and
committee depending on the available
notes which depends on the clerk and
historically that's going to be like a
one one two sentence summary for every
five-minute speech you know every five
minute bit of testimony so that's a
challenge
um for a judge to determine and so
they're going to lean to some extent I
imagine and I'm not gonna
speak too heavily to what judges think
but I think that they would lean to some
extent on just simply the way that the
law is written
and I do think that the way that it's
written currently doesn't take into
consideration employee employer employer
situations and supervisory and employee
situations and that's I am if I mean I
I'm I'm a little conf I don't know if
like we've kind of like lost the thread
in having a subcommittee
um and all of the different stakeholders
on the bill
and all the feedback and the amendment
proposals but that seems like that's the
issue that the sponsor brought up with
with the news articles that he gave us
the the person who was employing a
teenager in his landscaping business was
pretty clearly not
violating the laws that was written and
I don't know how we I guess the the bit
about provide services predominantly to
minors would be covered would cover the
carnival situation
um but you know I have a 16 year old she
worked at Market Basket since I mean you
know the uh the grocery store we won't
name that's a pillar of this community
um and is where you can save money
um but she worked there since she was 14
she applied the day that she turned 14
because that's the earliest she could
possibly work under the law and
um
she really enjoyed it but without a
doubt she spent a whole lot of time with
adults whose backgrounds we're not
familiar with and I do think that it's a
valid concern and Brad gave us this
handout and it looks like crimes against
minors
sex crimes against minors are included
in all three tiers so that I you know I
think I had been wondering during the
hearing whether
the RSA should speak to the type of
crime but it seems that that's not
really necessary because you if you're
on the registry
uh that doesn't mean that you've
committed a crime against a minor but
you've committed a crime that was
grouped in severity with a crime against
a minor of varying degrees but I was
going to propose since laptops and
subcommittee are
I think okay
and Googling in subcommittee I think is
okay I would like to look at because
didn't the landscaper thing go to court
and that's why it made the news I would
like to look at what the discussion was
in the courtroom and see if there's any
um
anything we can glean from that as far
as the functionality of the current law
I don't know if that would be helpful or
if I'm pushing us
off the rails on my own but I just want
to give my input on that but I really
think that what the sponsor wants to do
makes sense I think it's achievable I
think the list is
counterproductive but whether or not the
list is counterproductive might be
highlighted by anything that a judge may
have written about the Landscaping guy
so I'm gonna google that now Mr chairman
if I may yes thank you representative
one for being almost as verbose as I
tend to get because it gave me time to
read this amendment and refresh my
memory as to why I was against it
and I'm still against this amendment as
written this is this does not this does
not close the loophole when you read
paragraph one this is going exclusively
to people working uh with children in
such areas that I that I listed
um
schools after school that sort of stuff
but it leaves
it leaves the possibility of a
registered sex offender
hiring a minor child it leaves open the
possibility that a registered sex
offender is the direct supervisor of a
minor child
it leaves wide open the possibility for
a registered sex offender to be in a
position to work one-on-one with a child
that those three things that's the
loophole that's what the landscaper case
was all about that's what the
carnival ride operator case was all
about is you have registered sex
offenders
that are in direct supervision direct
management or employing minor children
that's the loophole that's the part that
we have to close this with all due
respect to to the representative does
not close that loophole
and that's why that's why I fought
against this floor Amendment on the
floor and I believe that's why this
floor amendment was rejected by the body
now I don't you know I can't say why
people voted certain ways but this this
does not close that loophole and so
while I don't disagree uh there probably
needs to be some wordsmithing around
direct
supervision language that's that's early
in that's that's the part we want to
that's the part we want to close I don't
think registered sex offenders should be
able to hire minors that puts those
registered sex offender in a position of
power over a minor who's already
a minor and doesn't have have the
knowledge that we have if if you're a
direct manager a direct supervisor of a
minor in your registered sex offender
that puts you in a position of power
over a minor that that shouldn't be
allowed if you're a registered sex
offender you shouldn't be in my opinion
we shouldn't allow that registered sex
offenders work one-on-one with children
without at least one other person there
to make sure the conversation the
activities don't go sideways that's
that's the loophole we're trying to
close well perhaps at this point we can
have representative Lynn speak to his
proposed amendment and his uh opposition
to it thank you Mr chairman thank you
thanks very much
so I guess
you know I think if if you were to ask
representative verbill and myself and I
suspect all of you
what
what do we want you know if we if we
were to give us all
an example of you know 10 or 20 sort of
situations and say where do you all come
down I suspect we would all come down in
the same place we'd all say yep in this
case the person shouldn't be able to
have this employment or this case the
person should the problem I have with
The Proposal that has that has been
offered and that is now before the
committee is when when if you say
that a sex offender can't have
and let's just let's take out the
business from it even if you say cannot
have employment
that provides Direct Services to minors
now representative verbal said well you
know we don't intend to prevent somebody
from working in the convenience store
but
the the courts are not going to be
they're gonna they're gonna be concerned
with what the law says and if it says it
pretty clearly it's not you know you
it's a very well established principle
if that if the law says something very
clearly you can't kind of go behind that
so the law says you can't provide Direct
Services to minors
so
you get hired to be the the checkout
person at Market Basket
and through the checkout line Comes The
Miner
aren't you providing Direct Services to
that Miner of course you are you're
providing Direct Services to the minor
and so that means that the person the
you can't a registered sex offender
can't get a job at Market Basket working
as a checkout person
now maybe you want to do that you know
maybe you want to say that although
and by the same token couldn't get you
know couldn't be the the person behind
the counter at 7-Eleven or Cumberland
Farms or whatever because again a minor
may be the one that comes in to buy or
you know a pack of gum and you're
providing Direct Services if you're the
so I guess my only concern here is
I'm no fan of sex offenders believe me
but if
they are gonna most almost all of them
are are not serving life sentences
they're going to be released from
incarceration at some point and then the
question really is
do you want them to be able to get a job
in any place where it's sort of relative
you know they're reasonably likely to be
able to get a job I mean
you know they're not they're they're not
likely to be getting a job as an
executive at BAE systems or something
like that you're talking about these
kind of you know relatively for lack of
a better term menial jobs that are most
likely the ones that they can get and if
you have a statute that prevents them
from even doing that you've essentially
a guaranteed they'll they're going to be
on welfare and we're all going to pay
for it and you know and and I don't
think we want to do that so
I have I guess I think
that
the the way the statute is exists right
now which contains this list of this
this you know list of things that are
explicitly prohibited I I I agree with
representative verbal that you don't
want that list to be the exclusive
because
um I I completely agree with that
um but I think that it does
it does
serve the purpose of kind of capturing
what generally the kinds of things that
are just flatly prohibited what we want
to say look you can't do you can't work
in these industries so to speak that are
you know that are sort of directed at
children
and then
what what the example I mean what what I
had proposed in my in the bill that was
offered in the amendment that I offered
last year was
um the the sort of catch-all at the end
which is
uh you know more broadly worded but it
what's that says or any employment or
volunteer activity that provides
services exclusively or predominantly to
minors now I'm you know I'm the I'm the
first to admit
does is that you know absolutely crystal
clear so that we you will be able to
tell every single case whether it fits
squarely within that or not no I'm not
sure you would ever be able to have
language that would do that but it seems
to me what it does do is it says that
if you know let me let me draw this
distinction
this would I would say this would not
prohibit a person from working as the
you know the counter person uh the the
checkout person that Market Basket or or
the uh the uh
counter the behind the counter thing
that's a 7-Eleven or Cumberland Farms or
and also wouldn't prevent
someone from for example getting a job
at a restaurant as a waiter where you
know where the where
the clientele of the restaurant is sort
of the general public is it possible and
you know that that that there will be a
minor that comes into the restaurant
sometimes sure
but I would say that and this would not
capture that this would not capture the
situation of a minor who is providing
services to uh who who Waits on the
table where there's a minor there it
wouldn't that that that employment would
be allowed under my proposal I would
draw this distinction suppose instead of
it being just a regular restaurant
suppose it's something like
and I'm trying to think of a good good
Chuck E cheese I think that was the one
it's it's something that is it's a kids
restaurant where the the in where you
know most of the people that go there
are kids
um it's not sort of generally I would
say then that is uh um
an activity that provides services
exclusively or predominantly to minors
and so you can't you can't work there
um and I you know I don't
um
is there
you know is undermine is there a is
there a a possibility you know for I
mean for example representative verbal
pointed out and I I guess he's I think
he's probably right I'd have to concede
this if you get a job at Market Basket
you're convicted sex offender you know
are will there be minors that are also
working at Market Basket well yes that's
true and so you know
um uh he I think he might he would call
that a loophole
I guess I would tend to you know
is it a loophole I I guess what I would
tend to say is if that's a loophole and
you want to prohibit that then
effectively you are you are you are
largely saying where does where you know
that sex offenders can't work in the
kind of jobs where they're likely to be
able to get a job and I guess the other
thing I would say is is it likely in
that circumstance where you know you
have a co-work you have a correct
registered sex offender works as a is
the checkout person at Market Basket and
there are other miners that also work at
Market Basket
is it likely in those circumstances that
the minor is going to be left alone with
the with the with the other person that
works as a as a checkout person probably
not it would seemed to me would be a
relatively unusual situation but I would
concede it could happen
so what you have to I think what you
have to do in the end is balance what
how restrictive do you want to be do you
want to give people registered sex
offenders any opportunity to be able to
work in the economy that's really the
decision you have to make
if I could um so
I'm looking at your proposed amendment
now I'm I'm for the the list being in
there uh I know in my experience a law
enforcement officer the list is good
because it gives some guidance as to
what types of things we're looking for
and there'll be no question that
specifically that list
there's no question about whether they
should be working there or not
adding the
part about
or any employment volunteer activity
that provides services exclusively
predominantly to minors
covers I think everything else like you
said
I think the concern from representative
verville is
the supervision of minors so aside from
it just being working in a place that
predominantly serves mine is that like
Chuck E cheese or something if they're
working at Market Basket and that person
is a direct supervisor of two or three
miners or a landscaping company if there
was some language in addition to
Services exclusively predominantly to
minus or in employment with direct
supervision of minors or they are short
not sure now that's that's a good point
I think that's that's I mean maybe you
could add on to the end of it or any
employment or voluntary activity
that provides uh Services exclusively or
predominantly to minors comma or that uh
uh or in which the the the the sex
offender would be the direct supervisor
of a minor yes
I'm sure because I I think I think we're
getting there I think we're getting
there really fast can I just say this um
so we can narrow this down in thinking
about time here
the section where you have a definition
under public private employer
organization as far as a background
check
I don't disagree that just citing
uh the section rather than redefining it
again
so perhaps we can just leave that as it
is it already defines it once in the
above section so in section B yeah
you're defining it again so rather than
do that I see in representative Lynn's
proposal
it says uh
oh yeah I specified a paragraph one
right I just referred just to clean that
up so we don't have two different
definitions or two different things to
look at it we don't have to address that
part of your proposal because it just
specifies whatever we come to as an
agreement on the
uh
first part of it that we're discussing
now you don't you understand what I'm
saying yes yeah I think that makes some
sense
thank you for letting me interrupt
um to be
feels like it's got to be a no-go I know
that it sounds great but practically
requiring every
organization of whatever kind in the
state to start doing background checks
um it seems like an undue burden and it
doesn't
and it confuses the issue because I
think the intent of the original Law is
to put the onus
on the offender
to dictate their own employment and that
when the offender fails to
obtain employment that complies with the
expectations set upon them then they
suffer the consequences I think that
this committee really needs to have an
amendment that eliminates to be sure I
don't think
we can move forward with that
requirement just because of the
widespread
effects that that would have on the
state
um but as for the landscaper I've read
the um well I'm going to say I browsed
the Supreme Court decision which I
believe has representative Lynn's name
on it
and it looks like and that you know I
don't know how much of this has already
been covered because I've been
multitasking but the conviction that he
got for employing a minor was overturned
by the Supreme Court and they said in
their decision
that more or less that the list was a
problem was the problem and it they said
um
we are not persuaded by the state's
statutory interpretation so the you know
the prosecutor's interpretation of this
law in part because it requires that we
not give meaning to all the words of the
statute but that we instead Focus solely
upon the phrase the care instruction or
guidance of minor children in isolation
we acknowledge the state's point that
its reading of the statute arguably
advances the goal of the statute to
prevent child exploitation and abuse to
a greater extent than our Construction
um
and then I don't know how to read
decisions but it says it frustrates
rather than effectuates legislative
intent simplistically
to assume that whatever furthers the
state's primary objective must be the
law
if the legislature disagrees with our
statutory interpretation it is free to
amend the RSA as it sees fit so
um maybe I think we're doing that now
maybe representatively all right I have
a point of order
I'm curious I walked in before nine
o'clock I assume we're doing some kind
of meeting on House Bill 107.
no this I'm sorry
Mr chairman I'm sorry if I just wanted
to say what that um what I believe that
the Supreme Court was trying to say and
representative Lynn could tell me if I'm
wrong but it seems like the state was or
the Supreme Court was saying that just
because we think that the legislature
intended or like that the goal of the
legislature would be to prevent
exploitation that results from people
meeting through a workplace or volunteer
situation that doesn't mean that the law
actually says that and it so it does
seem like the Supreme Court wanted to
eliminate the list and wanted the
legislature to work on
the wording and I would think they would
want to keep the list and just expand on
it yeah I don't think there was any I
think that what
I think what the court was saying there
was that the the
circumstances in that case were not
we're not sort of clearly covered by the
statute and that you know it is as I
tried to mention before it it it really
is a sort of principle of of judicial
construction of statutes that it if the
statute
doesn't cover something
even though if if you know if it did
cover it it would further the goal of
the statute it's not the job of the
Judiciary to say oh well that's great um
uh you know we're going to interpret the
statute as if it did because that would
further the goal the legislative the
court won't do that
Mr chairman if I may if I could just
hold on
you're from the sex offender registry is
that correct
do you have any any I just want to clear
this up because we have literally 20
minutes left here before and we'd have
to do another work session which which
is fine if we need to do that but do you
have any comments on that section would
that put an undue burden on first of all
your position and businesses where
virtually every business would have to
do a background check
s
okay Mr chairman if it would be possible
if we'd have one or two minutes before
we yield uh because I I made some cheat
notes I'm looking at representative
Lynn's cheat notes and our cheat notes
are getting remarkably similar um so I
think we might be closer than we we
think um at least on on on who's defined
by the law and so I guess my if if we're
going to use representative Lynn's
Amendment as the framework which is fine
then what I would ask is that we add
language that a registered sex of
language to the effect the registered
sector sex offender cannot be the
employer so that boxes out the
landscaper case right so if you're if
you're a business owner you you cannot
and you're a registered sex offender you
cannot employ minors because that puts
you in that power
employer manager supervisor
or work one-on-one with a minor right
those are those are really the four
things that I think we're trying to to
block out and as I I look I look at his
he's he's got direct supervision right
so we're very very close I would say we
just want a bar registered sex offenders
from being the employer being the
manager being the supervisor or working
in a one-on-one setting so if it's three
people on a landscaping crew one's a
minor one's a registered sex offender
and one is not if the the one that's not
leaves and the registered sex offender
has to go with them that you can't leave
the two alone I think if we added that
of a minor I think if we added that into
this
um I think we would be I think we'd be
in a happy place that we could
um all agree on with some other other
tweaks so with that I'll yield thank you
Mr chairman
foreign
one additional thing and I was actually
going to raise the issue of uh of uh of
uh of businesses as well there's also
the possibility that an offender can
actually own their own business that
primarily serves children
um that's why I say which I'm not sure
the statute addresses or the amendment
addresses at this point so for instance
they could buy an ice cream truck
um they could uh they could buy a Chuck
E cheese franchise they they could so if
we if we narrowly focus on on just
employment
um I guess my question for
representative Lynn is does that
preclude a would it would would we be
precluding people from buying an ice
cream truck no you know in fact you know
what I I mean that's a very good I guess
I would direct you I I tried to capture
that in so if you read
um six uh Roman numeral one six you know
the first what prohibition unemployment
of volunteer Services what it says is I
tried to capture that in there so a
person is guilty of a class a felony if
having been convicted in this or any
other jurisdiction of the various
offenses
um
it goes on to say he or she knowingly
engages in employment or volunteer
service then the crucial language either
as the employer or provider of such
services or as an employee or volunteer
so I try to that's that language is
different than the than the current law
because it tried in other words it's
designed to capture just what you said
so it's the you can't be the employer
or the employee
um and that that's what that's designed
to capture
a quick follow-up um
I've been working on another bill that
would ban uh the use of prone restraint
in New Hampshire and under the currents
one of the issues that we're having is
the current statute actually does ban
prone restraint but it doesn't ban it by
name and it doesn't Define it so it's
unclear to actually to people who are
actually
providing services to children that
that's not necessarily something that
they should be doing so my question is
is do we need to be more explicit than
that is it to avoid uh misinterpretation
or is that something that you think the
legislature should be concerned with I
don't know I guess I I think that you
know where it says that you can't do
these things
either as an employer or as an employee
or you know or a volunteer I think
that's you know that should that is
pretty clear
um so you know as representative was
saying I I think maybe we
we are in agreement on this what if what
if you added to the in my in my version
what if you added instead of ending the
sentence that says or any employment or
volunteer service that or volunteer
activity that provides services
exclusively or predominantly to minors
what if you then put a comma
so that that provides services
exclusively or predominantly to minors
comma
that involves the direct supervision of
minors comma or that involves one-on-one
work with minors
period I think that I think that kind of
covers
you know all of the things that we were
you know that representative verville
was was concerned about and that you
know that that
as sort of a loophole I think that sort
of covers it not
foreign
I think I think I know
if I think I know that representative
Lynn and I would love to work together
uh to come up with a new Amendment uh
perhaps uh we could recess this work
committee
um give us a week or two to hammer out
some some details and bring something
forth to the committee if there are
members of the committee that have other
concerns about other provisions of what
representative Lynn has brought forth
I'm certainly willing to to address
those two my my main concern has been
would be addressed by this and and so I
would yield to the committee members if
there's other parts of the bill that
that are causing concern or pause you
know we could certainly address that as
well representative
so on the part about getting background
checks those are getting tougher and
tougher to get because everybody wants
them and that system is just overloading
so they might be waiting weeks if not
months to get a background check to hire
somebody so right and that was discussed
and I think we're gonna hear from uh
representative all right uh on that part
of it this is specifically uh talking
about the part defining
the statute and the language and the
list and whatnot and I think you guys
are pretty close to coming up with
something that you both agree on
so that's probably the best course of
action is to let them work on that we
can uh come back when there's an
amendment to it however the other part
there with uh
section B I would like to hear
um some more information on that and
what the burden with that would be on
not only employers but on uh your
department as well
you had a question at some point
or testimony I'll have you in a second
here I just wanted to make sure that you
wanted to speak
I guess the other issue here is 2b and I
had similar concerns with that
if this is interpreted as McDonald's and
Market Basket and any fast food
restaurant or a restaurant at all or a
movie theater
all now required to have background
checks on everybody what kind of a
burden would that put on
on you
so in in talking with um
I'm talking with criminal records
yesterday would put a burden on uh
you know there's a 25 fee assigned to
those as what you know so the some of
the concern is
who absorbs that 25 fee uh if you have
multiple applicants applying for a job
you know when you've got uh you know 10
people applying for two jobs
they all need those background uh checks
does that cost get absorbed by the
individual applying or by the company
so those they do take time as well so
that would be an issue and again we're
not in opposition or in favor of law but
uh if we're solely talking about
criminal background checks and I won't
mention any of the other uh talking
points that I I kind of put together
here
um
but I I do have to mention one thing
that I hear continue to hear over and
over is
sex offender the verbiage sex offender
versus an offender against children we
have a number of sex offenders in the
state that have not committed any crimes
against children there are crimes
against adults so they don't fit into
any of paragraph one essentially that
says
felonious physical assault on a minor
or any assault or child sexual abuse
images they don't fit into those if
we're specifically talking about a minor
those also don't capture one of the
um
laws that a tremendous amount of our
offenders fall under and that's uh
would be use of certain Computer
Services prohibited which are the
offenders that actually are online being
caught by police departments that are
they're trying to lure minors
to meet them and and to have sex with
them so
that doesn't fit into any one of those
three sections above
so if they're convicted of those things
what happens so um
I'm not saying this should be the
verbiage but
you know perhaps any conviction
requiring the uh
offender to register and as if as an
offender against children Maybe
broader
in less
ambiguitous to us
law enforcement I think in some of these
instances
relative to what has been proposed we're
going to have our hands tied and the way
I see things is it is open to
interpretation but depending how that's
perceived by the individual officer or
the department or the person making that
claim I think that's going to put a
burden on those law enforcement agencies
to make that arrest or to bring those
charges forward
thank you I also have one of the
paralegals from the office who
so one of the big things and we're
talking about uh paragraph B here on the
bottom
how do employers and I think I brought
this up last time how do employers
interpret the criminal background check
so if you are applying for a job at
McDonald's or let's just say I don't
want to see I don't want to use a chain
restaurant but let's say a big chain
restaurant
and you've got a conviction in Tennessee
but now you're in a resident in New
Hampshire you apply for a background
check here it's going to show you in New
Hampshire New Hampshire background check
it's not necessarily going to pull and
it won't pull that Tennessee background
so you might have a conviction in
Tennessee that's not going to show up in
New Hampshire
so are the
restaurants now are they going to go by
the
are they going to get on to the offender
website and see you know this uh this
subject is a sex offender perhaps he's
going to do their the employer is going
to do that
they're going to look at the list
they're still not for the most part
going to be able to interpret that law
that that
RSA or that law that that subject or
that prospective employee was
um
convicted of
does that make sense to everybody it
does could could you explain how it's
done currently under current law
for the people for the obviously these
positions that are on this list here
girl scout School daycare do they get a
copy of the background check and
interpret it
so as far as if
if somebody's applying to like a daycare
yes I I don't know that they do at this
point um
quite honestly I don't know I don't know
how many Employers in the state actually
do criminal background checks I can't
speak for that so this is basically the
current laws prohibiting the sex
offender from applying for these jobs
not making these places get background
checks correct that's the way I that's
the way I read it
sorry I just want to ask a quick
question I know I I work as a homeless
advocate so I certainly need a criminal
uh justice I mean a criminal background
check or whatever what they do is it's
called Corey c-o-ri and I was under the
impression that that would be Nationwide
you would have all of the information
not just in in well where I work is in
Massachusetts not just in Massachusetts
but you know any criminal background
check is that not the case what is it
called Cori c-o-r-i I'm not familiar
with that that term
um I and that's the other thing too is
in this paragraph B
shall conduct a criminal background
check so and I think I brought this up
last time that means a lot of different
things to a lot of different people
perhaps a criminal record
check
from you know the state of New Hampshire
or somebody that would that's going to
be an actual criminal background check
but again if you're convicted in
Tennessee and we do a criminal
background check on you in New Hampshire
that's not going to flag if you live in
New Hampshire we're going to see your
New Hampshire
criminal record
isn't there two levels the state and the
federal yes so we should be doing the
federal they again it doesn't say that
but I know that that's why I'm asking
yes put that in so to capture everything
you need the second level the federal
checklist I would say so and then I
think to take it a step further
um and again I want to be clear we're
not in opposition we're just giving you
thinking points because we're on law
enforcement side are going to be the
ones dealing with the aftermath of this
I think
um to take it a step further
those offense who is going to interpret
those offenses so for example you might
have an assault and battery charge out
of let's say Massachusetts you live in
New Hampshire they find that assault and
battery charge that might actually be
a sex crime but it's not listed that way
it's it's assault and battery so the
employer how is the employer now
determining that they're not going to
have access to that police report
they're not going to have access to be
able to say oh yeah look in 1997 you
know he struck his stepson for you know
while attempting to do this they don't
have access to that they're not going to
be able to interpret that in my opinion
okay rep forever if you ever
what's in front of you does not make any
changes it's the best of my knowledge I
I I haven't prepared reference amendment
to my bill my bill doesn't change the
background checks from what's currently
in New Hampshire statute and apparently
is working quite well
so while I appreciate the remarks of the
current speaker and I've indicated I
would be more than happy to work with
them for a bill for next term to maybe
address some of those concerns they have
what's in front of you is not changed
the criminal background checks that are
currently in place for these things okay
as far as I know there's been no no
problems associated with that so I I
really wouldn't want to get this bill
bought down to that which is sort of a
different a different topic I think that
was a concern that's current language
um I think is is it exactly because it's
it's bold so there's some changes in
there as far as the definition of who
I I think that the only change that I
made in subsection to be
was it was simply you know to to instead
of lifting because I think the the
current law about sort of whisping again
the stuff that's in one
um I just said I just made a referencing
one yeah but I know there are background
checks done now I've done fingerprints
for School Employees so there are they
do them and I don't know who interprets
those but it's been done but nothing's
changed as far as that part of it with
current law right we're not changing
that
thank you
okay we uh literally have maybe four
minutes left here but thank you did you
have some comments or something you want
to quickly speak on on the bill
and and uh
you can just let us know who you are and
what what you want to speak about
you put the microphone on
good morning I'm Abby Simon I work for
Department of Corrections I am
administrator of Behavioral Health and
sex partner treatment program so I was
just wanted to clarify when looking over
this making sure and second what you're
saying because there are a lot of I
think just pull the mic you can pull the
microphone to which can you hear me
okay okay
um what I was saying is I just want to
Second making sure when we're looking at
this
um for people who have a sex offense not
everyone has a minor that has these sex
offense so limiting people who do not
have an offense against a minor
does not help them find employment as
well also we spoke in one of the
hearings previously about making sure
that their structure and routine for
people so that they're not reoffending
or coming back to the prison for other
reasons so just putting those points out
do you know if the current law includes
or any sexual assault
I did not change
felonious offense involving child sexual
abusive
for a felonious physical assault of a
minor
or any sexual assault some sexual
thought doesn't have to be against the
minor it could be any spectacular fault
and I think uh you know I assume the
legislation when they originally passed
that when the theory was there you know
I think there's some evidence that
sexual assault whether it's committed
against a minor or an adult that puts a
person at a high risk of community okay
yeah and that's current law and that's
not even being proposed as a change in
your Amendment so I think we should
stick to
the issues that we're discussing as far
as what your proposed changes are in
your Amendment you guys can work on that
are there any other questions here at
all for anybody
okay
I think at this point we could probably
maybe recess
and you guys will work on a Amendment
together that probably works together
and let us know and we will schedule
another
work session and see if we can't
come to an agreement on that and handle
that out
does that make sense to everybody here
thank you
here if the committee decides that you
want to make some changes to the
background checkpoints
I hope you don't when the roots are
representative if you do you know if you
let us know we'll
put that in too I would rather deal with
that as a separate building accent but
yeah
again because that's currently in the
statute so it was known to issue to deal
with it yeah thank you one more thing to
the to the extent that you can share
your Amendment with us before the the
next work session would be great I think
um my goal would be to make sure that we
get this through as a unanimous
recommendation and that will take some
work behind the scenes
okay and with that I'll close this
hearing
good morning
welcome to the public hearing for
criminal justice committee if you would
please join us in saying the Pledge of
Allegiance before we begin
foreign
yeah I didn't want to
okay thank you thank you very much I'm
president Timothy Horrigan from
Stratford County District 10 which is
the towns of Durham and uh
I see my former colleague Dr johannan
has put in a pink card and uh we served
adjoining communities for I can't
remember how long it was but like it's
good to see him again as always
and um
this bill the HB 191 it's act relatively
voluntarily surrendered firearms
and um it's essentially
um undoing a bill that was passed a long
time ago back in 1998 which is before
before I was in the legislature
and was signed into law by the governor
and that uh
Governor by the way even though she's a
Democrat I still think she made a
mistake and so I'm free to disagree with
honor it's uh seen Shaheen who's now
Senator Sheen
um
and uh so to added RSA
159.25 to the law book so that made it
illegal for the State Police to run
voluntary uh
gun buyback programs in fact it went a
step forward by forbidding any state
agency destroy any voluntarily
surrendered firearm and I don't know
and I think that would I believe that
would apply also to a County Sheriff's
departments and local police departments
um since they are I think they
would qualify as state agency so I don't
know if that's ever been tested or not
if any tried to do it so the uh
um so since
um so since the law was passed gun
owners may still in theory have the
right to destroy their property but they
cannot rely on the state police or any
other state government agency to do so
safely and um
according to an April 9 1995 New
Hampshire Sunday news article by
reporter Taylor who later worked
for the Hampshire speaker's office
um State Police at that time had a
simple and easy procedure for safely
destroying a gun and I assume they still
know how to do it and uh
I guess at the time what they suggested
was well you can go to a local gun shop
and do it but that's you know it's
somebody has a gun they don't want it
maybe they're not uh you know serious
gun owners maybe they're not used to
hanging around gun shops they may not
even know where a trustworthy gun shop
is or even maybe not feel comfortable if
they've been the victims of some sort of
trauma um
ironically since this is an old bill
it's easier to track down the bill files
than it does for recent bills everyone
like if you ever want to know what
happened to a build
that happened last week it's really
difficult to find the bill files but
they've digitized all the bill files for
this one including a SB sb65
1998 which is a bill this is overturning
and uh you know it was a very familiar
name as the prime sponsor which was
Senator David wheeler now the executive
counselor wheeler and um
also the former chair this longtime
chair of this committee David Welch
turned up in the debate and he had he
actually had kind of a strange story
where he uh well what it says in the
bill file he said he told the story
about a woman who accidentally shot at a
building his firearm was ceased and
remained in custody for four years
um
she voluntarily gave it up to police to
buy herself keep herself Reverend Welch
bought the gun in his head at three
years that's a successful outcome and
that was his that was our his argument
against passing the bill that he it
would have been really terrible if that
wonderful beautiful gun had been
destroyed instead of like finding a
loving home but representative Welch's
and he was he was a good man I can
imagine him I can just imagine how he
must have sounded when he's saying it
was probably kind of funny but it's a
strange why am I so strange thing and
also uh I mentioned that Dr Joe's here
he's
apparently resident gun owners of New
Hampshire and they were an organization
they had gone through several lobbyists
and spokespeople over the years but uh
they were instrumental in stopping the
voluntary
buyback program and um so that's uh
and actually it's another familiar name
associated videos was uh Ann leizak from
Portsmouth who's uh
husband was professor at UNH and my
parents uh knew both uh and lizac and
her husband Dr Richard lizac
he was shot on Maplewood Avenue in
Portsmouth near his home for really No
Good Reason by a young person who had a
had a firearm where they became they
became um you know they became gun
safety so she became a gun safety
Advocate after that and she was uh led
the opposition to the bill which uh
was not successful but I still think um
I still think
Banning uh Banning the destruction of uh
voluntarily surrendered Firearms was a
bad idea that's something that the state
police and other state agencies should
have an option and even uh
voluntary gun buyback programs I think
might be a good idea although there were
and uh so that's uh
the other going on probably pretty
pretty near my five minutes anyway but
um so what this bill actually is going
to do
it's a first of all this HP RSA 15925
which has not been amended since it was
passed back in 1998. the first line was
no state agency shall operate a Firearms
quote voluntary surrender and Destroy
program so that just crosses that out so
no state agencies
can operate a firearm voluntarily
surrender and Destroy programs and then
also uh the rest of it is the same
except then we add a third option which
was or destroyed by the state agency in
bold so that it adds that as an option
and uh
I guess when I drafted I figured those
were pretty much your three options
although I suppose there is the there is
also the option of donating the guns um
but uh you know perhaps we're you know
perhaps like you know for use by like uh
firearm safety programs or whatever but
so that's
anyway so then anyway so that's just now
they'll have the third option of
destroying the firearm which now they're
not required to do and I
don't know they get a huge number of
voluntarily surrender firearms and
testimony back in 1990 it was usually
about two or three a year but
still they're keeping to it I assume I
wouldn't have I assume there's uh I
assume that's probably continuing at a
similar Pace or more because there's
more guns on the street now so there's
probably like several dozen Firearms
just sitting in the warehouse that
the they they don't want to sell they
don't want to put in their own use and
they may as well be able to destroy them
especially if they're used you know some
particularly upsetting crime so
and um so finally just the last two
lines in my uh written testimony is
there are too many there were too many
guns on the streets in 1998 in spite of
what uh some of the people who supported
that bill believed and there are even
more guns on Street than else I say
there's like still too many guns on the
street and uh
so I think this bill would be a step to
uh you know reducing the number of guns
on the street so I would urge you to uh
I know that's not necessarily A
universally popular position on the
community on the committee but I think
you know I I think we can get a majority
of the committee in the full house
behind this pretty simple idea so that's
uh that's why I urge you to pass HP 191
thank you
thank you uh representative Peru has a
question
should add Municipal and County along
with the state that way you're making
sure you're grabbing everybody whether
it's a local police department or the
county sheriff
that way they definitely in in that
group that has to turn them into the
state for the auction oh yeah I would
view that as a a uh I'd view that as a
friendly Amendment amendment I see your
schedule to Executive this afternoon but
that's a simple simple Amendment so you
could probably get that is an OLS or you
could
put the bill off and execute it on some
future dates since it's not to the best
of my knowledge in early build so thanks
representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question are you aware that a
lot of local agencies will utilize ffls
to handle final disposition of firearms
that's in their custody
was FFL would you explain a little bit
more that would be a federally fire
licensed dealer
well sure I guess I'm aware of that and
that was uh I read the whole bill file
they often mentioned you can take it to
a gun shop which I guess in FFL I mean
this uh
but then the state police also have the
uh you know the state police have the
capability to also destroy guns they
were doing in 1995 I'm pretty sure they
haven't forgotten how to do it um
especially the state police's
institution with a lot of institutional
memory and also uh probably some of the
officers who around back then are still
serving now so I think I think if they
could do it uh 30 years ago as almost 30
years ago they can probably still do it
now and I think that might be more might
be more efficient in some cases and
bringing in the uh the Firearms dealer
thanks
representative Newell
so to be clear it's just saying that you
know that this is possible it's just
giving options for what to do with
voluntarily yeah so they can uh destroy
these surrender Firearms themselves and
they can also
if they so choose have a voluntary you
know surrender destroy or gun buyback
program too
thank you for your testimony this
morning
chair recognizes Mr blackton
I asked I tell this bill New Hampshire
is in need of any funds as we see at
White Farm Surplus sales as an FFL
I have had people and families call both
local and State Police asking what to do
with the state Firearms once somebody in
the family has passed and they no longer
want the firearms
they have been told they can be turned
into the state police who can dispose of
them and it is not always told to them
that they will be sold at auction or
used by the agency just that they will
take them
I often end up with these firearms and
in some cases sell them for the families
for money which is often needed by a
family
who somebody might not have but have
life insurance and costs are high and
the sale of those help that
as far as the surrender and Destroy
policy I object to that as it also can
be used as an end run to keep lawful
Firearms to shrink and some of these
Firearms may be high
sought after collectible Firearms or
parts guns for older guns
which if not kept by the agency should
be sold to boost the general fund
the New Hampshire State Police
even sell their own replaced firearms
and I have sold those
as well myself
so if the state police are selling their
own
replaced firearms
I don't see an issue that they should
sell
anybody else's firearms
and I think history if you look back
over the years
that the disarming of the citizenry
can lead to bad governmental actions by
some if they so choose Thank you
thank you for your testimony
chair I recognizes Dr Han
good timer today
don't worry I'll be quick uh good
morning uh Joe Hannon from Gunners of
New Hampshire uh we're in as you
probably already heard we are in
opposition to this bill and thank you
for the introduction before I appreciate
that
um I do however disagree with the good
gentleman from Durham uh Governor
Shaheen made a good decision when she
signed this into law
um for first of all it's a very fiscally
responsible thing to do to have a
something with value that the state
could sell to buy firearms for other
agencies to put back into the general
fund uh actually it all has to go to the
general fund but that money can be used
for any number of things in New
Hampshire so if you care about anything
in New Hampshire whatever that is
whatever is on your wish list of things
that's just a few dollars less for every
firearm this destroyed and it's not like
there's going to be more firearms on the
street necessarily because if someone
can't buy a used one at auction they're
gonna probably buy one somewhere else
the gun dealers are going to keep making
them if people want to buy one so I
don't see that as a net uh effect what
you do see is a net you do see is a
decrease in the maybe possibly more
affordable firearms for people who might
not be able to pay more money
um anyone's free to buy a quote-unquote
beautiful gun from any um you know from
the state if they're allowed to possess
firearms and if they so wish they can
have it destroyed take it somewhere else
and if that's their desire if that's the
purpose of this they can do that
um and and finally I'd like to say this
makes about as much sense as book
burning you know there's no reason to
get rid of something that you might not
agree with but someone else might be
able to use or it has value and that's
that's really all I said I'd be happy to
answer any questions
representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh representative
Hannah my question is you know I mean if
if I wanted to do that then why
shouldn't I have the option to do that
no I mean if I if I wanted to
voluntarily surrender it and have it
destroyed then I don't know that's my
choice I I know you may not like you
know me
um just throwing something like that and
I'm not saying that that would be my
choice I'm just wondering why we would
restrict people people's options and
what they want to do
cut me off I have no emotional
attachment to it so it doesn't it's not
a matter of you know destroying this
beautiful gun as we heard it called it's
it's a matter of like I said before a
value for the state if you want to have
it uh surrendered or destroyed you could
do that any number of ways you don't
have to have the state to it and the
state is losing the money and the and
the value
okay thank you you're free to do that
um still no choice Dr Hannan yes if I if
I want to destroy one of my firearms how
could I have that done uh actually
um offhand I believe I mean FFL can take
it they can do whatever you want you can
say I want to you know cut in half
whatever it takes uh I believe I'm not
sure if the ATF does it you might have
to contact them but you know it's not
against a law to break your own property
you know you could break your own as
long as you don't make it an illegal
firearm when you break you have certain
things could be a problem so if you have
a rifle and you break the back cut the
barrel and it's too short now you're a
felon uh for doing that even if it's a
functional fi even if it's
non-functional if you break the trigger
and then cut the barrel short you've
done it so there are correct ways to do
it anyone can do it if it's done
correctly but you could do have a you
know a gunsmith anyone can do it for you
and is to your knowledge is there a
shortage of gunsmiths in New Hampshire
uh not there isn't a shortage in this
room
[Music]
good point uh representative Muse
are you aware that there are are private
companies that will uh destroy Firearms
free of charge uh for law enforcement
agencies
great I didn't I I'm not surprised I
don't know them personally
but do you think the use of those uh
should be an option for our own State
Police
no and for all the reasons I just I said
I'm trying to get to the the reason for
that so if if they can be destroyed at
at no cost and that's the wish of the
property owner what what's the issue
why involve the state the property owner
can have it destroyed
if they like uh I mean I don't
understand why the state has to get
involved and lose money in the process
follow-up yeah
I I would say
um this this state actually
already seems to be involved in the
disposal of firearms So currently they
are accepting uh Firearms they're just
simply we've just simply precluded the
option of destroying them
so we already have the cost of accepting
those Firearms figuring out what to do
with them running auctions and sales and
things things like that it seems like
adding one more option for the property
owner to just simply check a box and
State Police pack these things off in a
crate once a month and to this company
that grinds them up or whatever they do
with them it doesn't seem to be
and an undue burden given the fact that
the state police already seemed to be
spending money time and resources
kind of addressing this issue
would you agree I would not agree thank
you and and I would say if they they
don't want to spend the money on an
auction and all that other stuff they're
more than welcome to deliver them to me
I'll give them my address if it's at no
cost and I'd be happy to take them off
their hands and out of circulation
I know sorry after the good
representative
thank you for your testimony thank you
thank you
the chair recognizes Mary Bonilla
good morning committee my name is Mary
penny I'm the lieutenant Lieutenant with
the New Hampshire State Police I've been
with him for about 19 years now a little
bit over
um just here for not to weigh on one
side or another just what it would take
with us because it will be something we
have to reintroduce into our
organization in order to have this
process go forward and how we would do
it and make motions to the court because
we don't just destroy anybody's Firearms
without the court giving us that kind of
permission to do it so we would it is
going to be a little bit more intense on
our side in order to do more reports
more motions in order to destroy them of
course we have a concern that if anybody
walks in with a firearm wants it sold
from the FFL or private sale to a
private sale you don't know who really
is the actual owner of that firearm and
was that firearm used in a crime at some
point and now we're destroying it so
just kind of things that we wanted to
bring to your attention who that primary
owner is
um is it destroyed or gone to auction
right now most of them are destroyed
that were used in a crime that we have
safe keeping on it also with this
statue that came forward unlike the
others where we return or destroy
property it doesn't relieve the state of
any liability if it is destroyed and
someone comes forward later to say that
was my property not theirs to give you
because we we can run into that without
tracing these firearms
it's the the law that was signed that's
currently the law have has your agency
had a had a problem with like having so
many Firearms you didn't know what to do
with them and wishing you could destroy
them
um we have not had a problem with so
many
um our division armor is in charge of
destroying those Firearms so he is the
one that's or his designee of who he
chooses to do that when he has that time
representative Newman
would the bill as written where it it
simply says it goes on or it just seems
to give the option to do that it does
there's no requirement in this bill for
them to do that
and even if a family wanted to have guns
destroyed I'm not sure what the
mechanism would be to try and get the
state to do that but the law does not
just gives an option so would that
affect your the way you did you uh as
you described
I'm not really understanding your
question the law itself does not direct
the state police to destroy voluntary
Firearms it only says that that is an
option
even if they came from a voluntary sale
and I don't I don't know if there's
another law that applies to that but
right now I don't see that it would
it's my belief that
would that cause you to additional work
if you just had that option to destroy
them it will provide some additional
work because we have to write a report
on everything that comes in along with
get that motion from the court in order
to move forward with that destruction
follow-up I I don't I don't see in this
law that the court has to be involved in
that you're saying every time that the
state police
destroy a firearm they need a court
order to do it for every single weapon
that's what we do yes thank you
keep your testimony thank you could you
um maybe you already did leave your
information so that we have any more
questions on this we could reach out to
you thank you
anyone else here wishing to testify on
this bill has not done so
seeing none I hereby close public
hearing
and the next one starts right now
okay we're in recess at 10 15.
this time I'm open to public hearing on
House Bill 305 and and recognize
representative minion to introduce his
bill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm here to introduce HB 305
I represent Hillsboro One Pelham uh so
last year I watched the testimonies of
last sessions uh House Bill 1178 there
was a lot of talk about this this week I
know you guys probably seeing me uh and
the concerns of granite Staters about
the language of the amendment of to the
bill uh they responded to me with the
current language
rsa159 E2 reads nothing in this chapter
shall prevent a state county or local
official from cooperating or rendering
Aid or assistance to Federal officials
with any in any circumstance where there
is reasonable suspicion to believe that
a person who is a subject of an
investigation for violation of federal
Arms firearms laws covered by RSA 159 E2
has also committed is committing or is
about to commit a violation of New
Hampshire law or a violation of a
federal law regulation order or practice
not covered by this section so
it says a violation of a New Hampshire
law which is extremely broad but what is
worse is a violation of federal law
regulation or order that nullifies the
entire purpose of the bill
if you've ever seen the at crime a day
Twitter account you can see where this
exception is very wide we create we
commit however many felonies a day is
the joke right so we're constantly in
violation of some federal law if you dig
deep enough
so my language here simply scales back
the exception to what I believe the
original intent to be
to prevent violent criminals from using
the non-cooperation language of 1150 uh
one sorry 159e as a shield for New
Hampshire law enforcement with that I'll
take any questions it's it's real it all
does is strike one line and make it
shorter in the existing RSA
representative Muse
what I'm what I'm trying to get at is
what are you trying to accomplish here
um what's and what what problems do you
think that this bill will solve so the
existing law right now has a massive
loophole that it basically nullifies the
entire purpose of the uh what we
consider the gun sanctuary Bill uh so if
an individual is committing any crime
Under the Sun whatsoever in New
Hampshire or federal which is if you dig
deep enough you're committing a crime
right now by breathing the wrong amount
of air or whatever it may be
this scales that back to make it so it's
very clear it has to be a class a felony
that the person is committing for our
law enforcement to cooperate with the
feds to enforce unconstitutional gun
laws
follow-up
and
my understanding is that this particular
law uh applies uh to Firearms correct
and second amendment issues
so off the top of my head
how many
Firearms related violations in New
Hampshire are class A felonies
can you give me a couple of examples
well it would be specific like like
they're not necessarily Firearms related
the way that the law is written right
now is it it says that they can
cooperate if any other violation is
occurring the reason this amendment was
originally added to the 1178 bill was
because from my understanding is the
attorney general wouldn't sign off on it
because what the way the language was
originally written is sounded like if an
individual was committing a federal
firearms law violation our law
enforcement were not allowed to
cooperate with the feds because we had a
the law the way the law was written it
basically shielded the criminal so if
they had like an uh a machine gun and
we're committing human trafficking we
couldn't help because they had the
machine gun and we're not allowed to go
after anybody who's violating or who
isn't violating a New Hampshire gun law
follow-up please
would uh would your change preclude New
Hampshire then from assisting a Federal
Officer with a kidnapping that crosses
over uh state lines no I do not believe
so I I'm almost certain that they so I'd
have to go back and look at the RSA
specifically defining all the class A
felonies as defined by New Hampshire RSA
and uh I believe trafficking and or
kidnapping is on those
but other federal crimes that are
non-firearms related there would be a
preclusion from also assisting with
those I stripped the feds because the
feds uh tend to
move around like definitions of of
penalties and and uh
crime severity thank you I didn't want
to be subject to their whims
could you give the committee an example
of a case or not a real case even a
hypothetical case where you think this
law should apply give us a scenario for
the folks so we can actually understand
what this law should accomplish
so the the existing law that's on the
books um as a hypothetical let's say
that I I had a suppressor like a
self-manufactured a suppressor because
I'm I'm trying to protect my own hearing
and I didn't go through the process of
getting a tax stamp right now if I had a
suppressor but was also technically a
growing up marijuana plant or something
along those lines or not a marijuana
plant but it had marijuana without you
know so it's not a criminal violation
here uh then
the fact that I had marijuana and that's
a violation of a federal crime or
federal law our local law enforcement
could help the ATF in enforcing that
that suppress the tax stamp violation
that I did committed right now the law
makes it now so just because I have
marijuana that's not good enough excuse
to bring in our state and local law
enforcement to help the ATF enforce that
unconstitutional law
thank you
representative Newman I sent a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for the
question very long taking my question
um I believe I've heard you say a couple
of times that that this law prevents
New Hampshire
police to assist the feds in an
unconstitutional gun law and I'm curious
if you can give me an example of exactly
which gun laws that have not been
deemed unconstitutional by the Supreme
Court which ones that are currently
enforced how how can you say that they
are unconstitutional to the Federal
Constitution right the bill doesn't
specifically say I'm using my own
opinion of these laws shall not infringe
is quite straightforward and I think
anything that infringes is
unconstitutional by my definition
okay so it's just your opinion yes those
you're not saying that the federal laws
that have not been overturned by the
that's correct I apologize for the for
the being unclear thank you very much
seeing no further questions thank you
chair recognize representative Morgan
um thank you very much um Mr chair I can
you be resident Timothy Horrigan I
continue to represent uh Stratford
County District 10 which is the towns of
Durham
um and I hope our colleague Revenant
selig gets well soon she's watching on
YouTube but at least she was watching
the previous hearing on YouTube so it
um
and I was glad the member refreshed my
memory that it was HP 1178 because I was
which I thought that's what it was what
this is about now he's going nuts
because these this RSA 159e which is
what was established by uh
HB 1178 is not listed in the uh Bill uh
not yet listed in the build database so
that's uh that's just thought I'd
mentioned and I'm sure there's other
rsas we have that problem with so I
think the uh sponsor of this bill I
think pointed out the whole premise
behind HP 1178 was uh irrational like um
you know there's you know just about any
federal offense if the person owns a
firearm can become
can become at least in part of firearm
offense and um I personally don't think
that's uh
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that I don't really know why guns
should be treated separately from any
other dangerous thing and certainly um
HB 11 78 has created a lot of uh
irrational situations like for example
uh here in my community we have a new
we have a new middle school that has a
lot of security precautions whether
somebody
uh somebody gets through the security
cautions with a gun
um they're
school's not quite sure whether what
they can do aside from putting the
lockdown whereas uh
see if the person came in with a suicide
vest and a bomb you know I guess that's
not covered by the Second Amendment if
you're waving a chainsaw around that's
obviously not covered by his second
amendment or if you're a
if you barge into the ladies room that's
not covered by the Second Amendment
unless of course you're wearing a gun
while you do it there's lots of uh
yes there's lots of situations so I'm
not sure you know so like uh where they
at least feel like they're they're
hampered in the ability to deal with
certain types of threats that they might
reasonably expect to uh expect to have
and certainly it makes it a lot harder
to take preventive action um
and there's a myriad of things uh Myriad
things like that and also uh
presidential executive orders
um I mean I'm not a big fan of them but
they are necessary sometime and uh the
current president is not the only one
who's issued executive orders uh
governing uh the keeping or bearing of
arms so the previous one did too he put
on the executive order after a massacre
in Las Vegas Banning bump stocks and uh
the people who are so worried about the
current president's executive orders
were not worried about that presidency
exact orders and I understand that's how
it is when it's your your guy just like
you know I voted for the current
president so I'm inclined to cut a more
slack than it was a president I hadn't
voted for so that's fair enough so um
I just sort of so I think uh you know I
think they've I think I think uh it's
monsters Phil has indeed
uh seen an illogical uh
in a logical element of the uh of the
bill that we passed last year and I
think the best solution uh those would
be a Germain amendment to this bill
there is another bill that just uh
eliminates the whole eliminates the uh
eliminates the whole whole the whole HP
1178 RSA 159e so I think that's uh
that's probably the better way to go
rather than trying to fix in this bill
one last thing we have
we already have a big problem in the
courts system and I serve on the
Judiciary Committee so I'm made aware of
this on occasion so we have a problem
with overcharging uh
overcharging defendants so this will
encourage the police if they're
investigating something and uh they
think the person is a firearm and
probably just about anybody might have a
firearm they'll start charging people
right off the bat with class A felonies
even if they don't think that's what an
appropriate charge so we already have
enough problem with overcharging people
and this is just going to encourage our
police forces to uh
maybe even
charge everyone who's doing something
suspicious
that he might be going to trial with a
class a felony just so they can continue
to work with the federal officials and
it's um certainly not uh
and as I said to a certainly illogical
to single out Firearms laws you know
they're no different than like anything
else that's dangerous in our society and
they should be uh treated the same way
rather than be given this sort of
special status we give them so I
um
so I think I think I probably urge you
probably your best course of action is
probably to retain this bill and then in
case the HB 78 the
hb15 which repeals this whole law
passes and he can or fails you can use
that to as a vehicle for further uh
further action in that area but I don't
see what's nothing good really can be
accomplished just by this one change
even though it's seems like a simple
change so
so thanks that's and that's what I had
to say about it and I I guess I'd be
happy to take any questions although
thank you for your testimony thanks
I apologize for any two partisan but I
just felt I had to meet the point thanks
all right thanks no worries
um anyone else wishing to testifying
this bill sure
are you sure
there ain't no others hereby close to
public hearing on HP 11 3 excuse me HP
and the committee is now in recess until
11 A.M
foreign
six seconds
yet it starts that's it
okay
foreign
that's fancy
all right
morning at this point we are opening the
executive sessions
and we are starting with the executive
session on House Bill
and I recognize representative Prue to
make a motion
a second
I'll second Mr chair
oh
okay uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative pru
I think these are mostly Antiques and
what have you but um again they fall I
believe under the Second Amendment to be
able to protect myself if so needed I
mean most people can carry a gun now
without a permit so
something to carry in your pocket I'm
okay but
would you like to speak to you second
uh thank you Mr chairman um
no
alrighty discussion
I I'll just start by saying that um this
is just an Antiquated statute
there are far more lethal things
available today than these
as representative Bruce who have to put
antiques
um so I I just don't see any need to
keep them in statute is prohibited
um but anyone else
representative gathway
I have a real concern for this bill
and um particularly for students
High School
Middle School
um
I think the law is in place for a reason
and it's been there for a very long time
and when you think about the um
what they call this the the
slung shots
very dangerous weapon that's the one
that has the balls on the end of it you
can throw them like this
no that's what it is and um I just think
that is it's a very uh
can have quite a few unintended
consequences if we would have passed
this bill
so I will not be voting to pass such a
horrible bill
okay representative Muse
during the testimony we did hear these
framed as uh Antiquated non-lethal
defensive tools
um when I actually looked up things like
brass knuckle injuries in Google and
looked up injuries from some of these
other things
what I found is uh these aren't just
being kept on a shelf and treated like
antiques there was a video that I saw of
a woman who is sitting parked at a
traffic light somebody using brass
knuckles shattered the window of her car
assaulted her punched her face pulled
her out and the the difference which was
shown in the video between what what her
face looked like before that assault was
committed on her and what she looked
like afterwards
was horrifying
these are our weapons uh that can you
imagine if people started taking them
into bars
started getting a little intoxicated
imagine a situation where
police had to go into a bar after some
kind of disruption and uh you know and
try to arrest uh you know people who
were wearing these and who were using
them
um
passing this creates a huge potential
can of worms for New Hampshire it
creates a can of worms for our law
enforcement Personnel
we have a statute that may not be used
that much right now but the fact that
it's there may be keeping people from
doing some of this stuff and using some
of these things against other people and
to me that's a perfectly good reason to
keep the statute on the books and so I
will be voting against the motion of
ought to pass
thank you representative Manion
thank you Mr chair
um
we have laws in place for the use of
these weapons this is just a possession
of these weapons so that wouldn't change
uh if someone were to use these in a
manner that violates another statute
however if I was that woman in the car I
would have loved the opportunity to have
a pair of brass knuckles on myself to
defend myself against that attack
thank you
um actually that that made me remind me
of a commercial I saw um Watson log on
television where they were marketing
apparently to women some kind of claw
device that a woman could use to defend
herself
um and I don't think that would fall
into these descriptions but it had like
made you look like that that guy with
all the blades on his finger from the
Marvel movies
um so that there's there's that swords
are illegal uh this this is just several
things but um there's still a whole
plethora of things that are legal so
my support was based on the fact that it
just narrowly these things but anyone
else
uh representative janvard
thank you Mr chairman uh I'm of the
opinion that
our Second Amendment in the United
States Constitution guarantees us the
right to bear arms these are clearly
arms although Antiquated and to speak to
representative Muse's
um concern
I just looked up RSA 631-1 first degree
assault
person is guilty of a class a felony if
he
I'm going to the second one purposely or
knowingly causes bodily injury to
another by means of a deadly weapon so
it's already illegal to use it in an
unlawful way
and and possessing it is not using it in
an unlawful way it is a defensive weapon
if it's used in as an offensive weapon
it is then a crime
so I support the OTP
representative scitec
always just very little of the
committee's time my understanding is to
the Twin Towers were brought down with
box cutters
okay
anywhere else
seeing no one else the I will ask the
clerk to call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative Prue
yes
representative janfrin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
no representative Bolden
no
representative Bradley no
representative Murphy
no
representative Newman
the clerk votes no representative Newell
yes
representative nothing Wong
no
uh chairman Roy terrible yes
motion passes 11 8.
yeah
could you say the vote again please
thank you
motion passes 11 8.
without a closed the executive session
on House Bill 31 I opened a House
Executive session on House Bill 89.
and I will
recognize
um actually
myself I will be um
offering an amendment
I'll spill 89
and it is amendment number zero three
seven zero I believe the
oh that's the wrong one
wait a minute which one's this oh this
this amendment has not yet arrived from
OLS I'm going to recess this and we're
going to pick it up in a little bit once
I'm able to check with Karen there's an
amendment on the way
foreign
I'm going to open the executive session
on House Bill 158
and recognize
representative stone for a motion
this is on 158 yep
I would make a motion to itl this bill
okay second
would you like to speak to your motion
Mr chairman I would
this bill is presented with uh
turn thousands of law-abiding citizens
in New Hampshire to felons a large
majority of common hunting rounds can
penetrate ballistic vests and slash
armor in its National course
therefore I feel this bill has really no
value for Public Safety
representative mannion
I concur with uh representative Stone
um discussion I'll I'll start off I just
would say that the police haven't asked
for this the definition
um is is really
um
confusing and it would in fact make many
rounds that have no relation whatsoever
to the subject matter become felonious
possession just because they're hunting
rounds
um I I the the the bill if it were to be
worthy of passing needs a lot of work
and we're just not doing that right now
so representative
um who's oh representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I I would just
like to add that while the sponsor I I
believe had
you know good intentions as as he um was
here with the testimony there was a lot
of questions that were not able to be
answered and one of the the one that is
glaring in my face is
If This Were to pass then what happens
with the ammunition that people
currently have and you know that was
just well I guess it would be phased out
over time but I think we all know
exactly how that would would be
implemented and again it was not able to
be answered so I just think that I agree
with the um Ito motion
I would also add um and I didn't I
should have
um this is a true armor-piercing
ammunition is already federally illegal
um in possession of it as a federal
felony
um and that's the stuff that really does
actually designed and made for piercing
body armor and it is used for military
purposes
further discussion
um representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to point out to the
committee that the definition used in
this bill was pulled from an existing
RSA so while I agree with the itl motion
I think that maybe we should examine
that RSA in the future to provide more
clarification
thank you good point
anyone else
being none the I'll ask the clerk to
call the world
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzar yes
representative Harriet gothright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative netting Wong
yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
motion passes 22.
motion passes 2-0
consent no objection heard
I hereby close to public hearing on
excuse me the executive session on HP
open the executive session on House Bill
216.
and I recognize representative Muse for
a motion
take your time
motion by representative Muse seconded
by representative gaps right
representative Muse would you like to
speak to your motion
yes I I understand that there are folks
who believe uh that this drug should be
Exempted as part of harm reduction
strategy
um however I don't believe in uh that
simply uh removing it uh as a controlled
drug under the controlled Drug Act would
actually accomplish uh harm reduction
um I think what it would accomplish is a
lot more people taking a drug that
should probably be taken under some type
of medical supervision if it's going to
be taken at all in situations where they
may not have help available to them one
of the things that we heard during
testimony is that while there are there
are substantial number of people who
seem to get a benefit and derive some
type of psychological benefit from from
taking this drug we also heard that
there are other people who have who have
bad trips and uh and where there can be
significant consequences to taking a
drug like this
without
sometime type of help being nearby if
something goes wrong so I I
am sympathetic to the idea of a
decriminalizing uh
some things in our controlled Drug Act
but at this point in time the way this
bill is written this would not be one of
them
representative gaththright would you
like to speak to you a second
that
further discussion representative Newell
well I am very much in favor thank you
Mr chair well I'm very much in favor of
decriminalization and regulation I think
that those two things go hand in hand
and I think that there's a process for
that and concur with what um
representative Muse
Right Said
thank you representative wheeler I think
that adults should be able to make the
decision to be stupid to be weird or to
have a bad trip if they so choose and I
think the state stepping in and saying
that you're not allowed to take a drug
which the only harms I could find online
in research or we were told about were
as representative Muse said a bad trip
and I think that's not a significant
enough harm it doesn't harm another
person and if someone isn't harming
another person with their choices then
they should be allowed to make stupid
decisions so I will be voting against
the ideal motion
thank you
representative scitec
we heard testimony that this was not
addictive when I heard the state police
had their opportunity to speak they had
very little to say it was just a general
uh dislike
uh I think
um
next are we going to out if there's if
there's no addictive properties are we
next going to Outlaw pleasure so I'm
going to be voting against the ITIL
I believe pleasure has already been
outlawed at the federal level
anyone else
oh representative proof
I appreciate you trying to keep me my
job and working because I'm the one who
go get gets the bad trips but uh
uh I'm still gonna vote against it
thank you for that
um so you know what else I'll ask the
clerk to call oh who's going to miss can
I just add one more thing for the record
this drug was legal to buy online until
2011 in my research I had a few
questions and no one could answer that
too well but in my research it was legal
to buy online until 2011 and we hadn't
had a problem uh until the federal
government decided to step in and make
it illegal for uh no well documented
reason hence my comment about pleasure
being unlawful
um representative Muse
one thing I would like to point out is
the court has basically ruled according
to the testimony that we heard that it
is still legal and appropriate for
people to use this drug for religious
reasons uh and nothing about italing
this bill would actually change that
thank you
I will at this time ask the clerk to
call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative Prue yes
representative janvin
yes
just as a reminder the motion is itl
representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
no
representative Bradley no representative
Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes no representative Newell
yes
representative netting Wong no
representative wheeler
chairman Roy earphones yeah
motion passes uh
15 to 5.
we have a count discrepancy again
okay you said fifteen five at first okay
fourteen six is the correct the result
is the motion carries uh 14 to 6.
for the record at this point
um I closed the executive session on
House Bill 216.
I opened the executive session on House
Bill 315 and I recognize representative
myself as an emotion as from
this
is I would like to introduce an
amendment
and now it's the amendment zero three
seven zero H and I'll speak to the
amendment the amendment does not do
anything to the bill that was brought
before us except for it adds an
additional
um additional line
and it says
the provocation was not uh was not
objectively reasonable if it resulted
from the defendant's hostility to a
decedent's religion race Creed sexual
orientation as defined by RSA 21 colon
49 national origin and this is the part
I added political beliefs or affiliation
or gender identity as defined under RSA
the reason I added that is because in
the climate we're seeing today we're
seeing
politicians non-politicians people
getting getting shot getting killed
because of their political beliefs and
wherever we have a chance we have to
reiterate our first amendment and our
rights to believe the way we want
and
I feel like this is a good spot to start
and since the the sponsor was kind
enough to bring this to my attention I
believe that gender identity and the the
whole gay defense thing is outrageous
and it shouldn't be shouldn't be used
um generally speaking I'm in favor of
the Court being able to decide that but
sometimes we have to as a legislature
let the courts know the mind of the of
the populace
and that's where I stand in that
um
I thought you seconded it can anyone
retroactively second that for me please
okay it's been seconded
thank you
I'm through and
um discussion
representative Muse
one of the things I think that I'm
wondering is whether the amendment
um
accomplishes the original attempt intent
of the sponsor of actually prohibiting a
gay Panic defense uh
and another question would be are we
opening the door to a uh
a a
Democrat Panic offense a republican
Panic defense say
um uh racial Panic defenses I mean I'm
trying to uh to kind of understand are
we
is the amendment actually germane to
what was originally proposed or are we
actually enacting something very very
different
well as I I left the um the sponsor's
language intact except for additions so
the sponsors intent is not affected as
far as I'm concerned
and it only expands upon it
and if we look at what's already there
we had race Creed sexual orientation
um oh we added sexual interesting we had
race Creed national origin all of the
things that people
so did we already have a a race uh Panic
did we have a religious Panic
um
I think that if we're going to extend
this protection as a society we should
look at what's happening in our current
time
and right now we we see political
violence on the rise
so whether or not it's going to be a
panic defense or any defense at all it
should not be allowed as a defense to
killing someone
so um that's the reason for the addition
I do not think it takes away from it
simply adds to taking away the gay Panic
defense and also adds to that religious
excuse me political beliefs so that and
follow-up sure absolutely yeah um so you
you had said you you're you're you're
basically saying that the amendment
um uh doesn't replace any language it
actually adds language but but there is
language in the original Bill uh in
section four uh uh
for instance that does uh say that if
the provocation was not objectively
reasonable it says that basically the
provocation is not objectionable
objectively reasonable if it resulted
from the discovery of knowledge about
the potential disclosure of the victim's
actual or perceived gender gender
identity sex or sexual orientation
including under circumstances under
which the victim made an unwanted
non-forcible romantic or sexual Advance
towards the defendant or if the
defendant and victim dated or had a
romantic sexual relationship there's
also some additional language that says
in section four that says nothing in
this paragraph shall preclude the jury
from considering all relevant facts to
determine whether the defendant was in
fact provoked for the purposes of
establishing subjective provocation
there's also a a section B that that
defines gender for the purpose of the
paragraph So
I I'm a little confused because the
amendment actually seems to eliminate a
lot of language that was in the original
bill as opposed to just supplementing it
and could you comment on that yeah I
would actually
um the the language the purpose of the
bill was to defend it was to prohibit
the gay
um
the gay Panic defense and that's clearly
still here the sex or gender without
getting into as the original Bill did
about dating
um and into the nature of relationships
in in my opinion it shouldn't matter
what the relationship is if you kill
someone and say you did it because they
were gay
um whether you were dating or you
surprised them or what you did is in my
mind you're relevant you killed someone
you're trying to get away with it
because you're saying to a guy so I did
remove the part that described
relationships
as far as the gender identity it's
already in Statute in RSA 21 colon 54.
um so that a purpose having it in there
for the purpose of the statute
we can't have conflicting definitions we
should have one definition in statute if
we're going to define something in
statute so having different chapters
with different definitions of the same
thing is not helpful so again I would go
back to the intent of the sponsor was to
alleviate or remove the gay Panic
defense this does that and it just makes
it a little broader without putting in
language that is so specific to a
certain scenario
um
that it narrows it so much that it's not
able to protect anyone else except for
those specific people in those specific
scenarios represent Manning you had a
comment
or did you have your hand up no who had
to hand up representative Reed thank you
Mr chairman
um I felt the original bill was very
narrow so when I heard the amendment I
was much more comfortable with passage
with the OTP I felt it was it was made
better and more inclusive by adding all
those other components so I like the
amendment very much
with thank you
all right thank you Mr chair
um well I appreciate the intent of the
amendment because I do agree that we
need to make sure we protect all people
from these kinds of
um defenses in court
um my concern is that there is legal
precedent of the gay Panic defense being
used specifically in these situations
where their surprise dating
relationships involved and because
there's that legal precedent with those
specific group of people and to my
knowledge there's not that same legal
precedent where people have been able to
say oh I you know have a momentary burst
of insanity because of someone's
religion and that has ever been used to
my knowledge in any case whether
successfully or not it's two very
different issues and I think it would be
more applicable to the intent of the
bill and also clearer to
um those enforcing this law
to be specific about what we're trying
to prevent and then in the future we can
do a different bill which addresses
these other categories that we also want
to protect but I think that this muddies
and Waters down the original intent of
the bill and could possibly still leave
a loophole that would be abused in the
future
thank you um I would respond to that
um
I recall I'm old enough to remember
after 9 11. there were quite a few
people that were taking action against
people of the Islamic faith and they
panicked because oh my God are they a
terrorist and some people were indeed
hurt by that
further the the we have to in my opinion
as a as a committee and as a legislature
we don't pass laws to send political
messages and if the intent was this we
want to send a message and we're going
to get so specific
either the bill or the law is to protect
people and we enumerated certain groups
of people
then it's to defend those people the the
message or the intent
isn't isn't the reason we make law we
make law to protect people and I agree
with you it has been used in other
jurisdictions never in New Hampshire and
it was not successful the gay Panic
defense uh or hasn't been in in quite
some time so the argument could be made
it's really not needed however having
said that
to protect from it ever happening in New
Hampshire were saying let's pass this
I say the same time why come back later
when we have a chance right now to
protect all of these people in these
classes from anyone having any kind of
excuse where they think they can get
away with murder because of someone's
religion someone's race
um
are all these things are so much
political beliefs but again we are all
free to
representative scitec
time representative Newman I just have a
question you mentioned the bill that
this that the definition conflicts with
but I did not get the number of the bill
and I'd like to
see if they are comparable or if it two
different two different definitions are
appropriate
is it in the amendment
I say okay thank you very much I I see
it's on there thank you
foreign
Bolden
I just wanted to throw in just food for
a thought that I think historically it's
it's easy to forget because we live in
this world now of like
we have rules where a nation of laws and
and we grew up thinking we know what
what is expected of us and that murder
is always improper that physical
violence is always improper but it
wasn't that long ago that
cultural perspectives were different and
that those differences in cultural
perspectives
were used
to justify violence but not
they weren't capitalized on to justify
violence they genuinely Justified
Violence in those cultures in Prior
prior versions of this country
um
I'm sure you've all heard about old laws
about like maybe the thickness of the
whip you can use on your wife for
example
um and we know that there's been shifts
over time about physical punishment of
children and I think most recently
where that translates is uh there's I
guess the most prolific serial killer I
think his name is Sam little he
specifically targeted sex workers
because he knew that they wouldn't be
valued and he argued when he was caught
from time to time he would say well she
was stealing money from me or she wanted
to do something weird
and then he was let go by authorities
because they found that to be a
Justified reason for whatever his
violent Outburst was so there are people
alive today who do take into
consideration your reasoning for a
violent act they don't think that it's
black and white the way that some people
may think it is today that you just
shouldn't be violent and their own
biases do go into their evaluation of
your behavior
um and I just
wanted to throw that out there
um because
the situations in which the bill at hand
would be important are going to be very
maybe even singular situation if ever
hopefully right maybe never but it would
be a very complicated situation in which
someone lost their life and I hope that
um we can
make decisions with that in mind thanks
thank you and that that reminds me of
one other thing we just in this
committee discussed the other day about
needing to do a certain thing because
there are continuously new residents
coming to our country from different
places who bring with them their their
biases and culture ideas and until they
can acclimate to our own things like
this where it may be acceptable for one
religion to to to use violence against
another uh to clearly spell it out that
is not an excuse in the United States to
use violence or race or sexual
orientation or or your gender identity
or any of these things or or political
um I just think if we're going to do it
let's do it and make sure we that
everyone possibly could be covered thank
you
at that I'm going to call the have the
clerk call the roll
just a reminder this is just a on the
option of the amendment
and the motion was
um
otpa or is that
OTP yeah OTP the amendment
adopting the amendment that's what I
thought yeah adoption okay
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative Peru yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes
representative tenzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden
yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes now representative
Newell yes
representative nutting long yes
representative wheeler
motion Pat oh sorry chairman Roy
thank you uh the chair of votes yes
motion passes 19-1 at this point I would
like to make a motion of otpa
seconded by representative pru
um I think that we've spent enough time
discussing it because the the first the
motion on the amendment covered the
actual bill I think that um there's no
excuse to kill anyone
and
for anyone who might contemplate making
one out of these reasons in the
amendment that we just passed
um they're not going to be able to and I
think that's a step in the right
direction and I applaud the sponsor for
bringing this bill to us and certainly
want to recognize the importance of the
the um
of killing any anyone thinking of using
the gay defense as an act of violence so
with that further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
again the motion is otpa
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Harriet gothright representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative wheeler
aye
chairman Roy
cheerful GS motion passes 2-0.
motion passes 20-0 it will be on consent
barring objection no objection seeing
none I hereby close the executive
session on House Bill 315. I hereby open
the executive session on here by excuse
me on 4C 473
and I recognize representative Rhodes to
make them excuse me
to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
make a motion of ought to pass for house
bill 473.
second second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chair
um
we had heard in the testimony reps Hall
about
for for a first time
defense about the criminal pennies
penalties and what that does
um
you know the the impacts of a person's
job and or being able to gain employment
afterwards and we are not changing
anything about about possession or any
of that part of the law this is
basically just a
just to I I guess it's almost uh given a
person a chance for that for that first
time offense to be able to bring things
back together and give them a second
second chance around
thank you representative gather I would
like to speak to you a second
um I'll start discussion I brought this
bill
because not because I think that we
should be
um
weaker on on the use and Drugs in this
in this state but because we need to
stop making felons
um
the effects of a felony on someone's
life at a young age are almost
incalculable it carries them and follows
them the rest of their lives and it
almost makes
the hope of redemption and change out of
Out Of Reach and it it just sends them
automatically on a mental path where I
can never get rid of this felony and the
incentive to better themselves is just
taken away and when I saw the disparity
that with which this affects communities
um of color in in this state and across
the country I think that we need to stop
making felons of our of our young folks
and and when they make a mistake give
them a chance to get help and back on
track and
they're just I just don't understand why
we would want to continue making these
people felons on such a level
um so quickly so that's that anyone else
representative Newell
um I would just like to add um I'm
absolutely in support of this Bill thank
you for bringing it
um and agree with all the things that
you said also I think you know we really
we need to make a shift in how we deal
with people who have issues with
substance use or you know um it it is a
matter of
um treating people as if they are a part
of our community or other Rising them
separating them and making them a felon
is is essentially what you are saying
putting somebody at a disadvantage
putting them outside of our community
and only harm can come from that so I
just wanted to kind of just expand on
what you said
thank you
any further comments discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
motion is OTP Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt no
representative scitec
representative Prue yes
representative janvin yes representative
mannion
no
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes
representative Harriet gothright
yes
representative Mia's yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative nutting Wong
yes representative wheeler chairman Roy
motion passes 18-2
it's crackling
questions
finally
oh
incredible
interesting too
foreign
the house
thank you
it was made of the children
English
a one two okay I'll restart the system
microphone check one two
what did you do
typically it's one that was unplugged a
little bit so it could have been anybody
yeah
I could do it too yes
like Christmas lights yes yeah red is on
and yeah
testifier bike one two
thank you
little brains
you want that one because it it was
unanimity
testing
okay at this point we're going to resume
our executive sessions and at this point
I'm going to open the executive session
on House Bill 89 that we shortly recess
while we waited for an amendment and I'm
going to recognize representative Muse
to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I would like to move
uh Amendment uh
2023-0472h to pass
it's uh zero four two h
04728-0472h yes Mr chairman I'll vote
I'll I'll second the motion on the
amendment seconded by representative Jim
representative Muse would you like to
speak to your motion yes um the
amendment is to uh to HB 89 this is the
bill that would actually annul uh the
convictions of goody coal and will it up
house in New Hampshire
um uh the amendment actually addresses
some concerns that uh House Council had
about some of the the language that was
used in the original Bill and so
essentially the amendment dot CIS
crosses the t's and helps us achieve our
objective which is to pass this bill
without any legal issues down the road
thank you
representative Jammer would you like to
speak to you a second
yes Mr chairman thank you uh
in 2020 I co-sponsored HB 1269 which was
this same bill
um I I was joined by all of the
representatives in the town of Hampton
and I
currently represent the town of Hampton
as well in this in this uh by any name
and
the the
exoneration of goody coal is long
overdue so I I support the amendment and
the underlying bill
thank you any further discussion
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll
motion is for adoption of amendment
Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt no
representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Harriet gathright yes
representative news yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy gerbilts yes motion passes
19-1
at this point I would uh recognize
representative Muse for another motion
Mr chair I move HB 89 ought to pass with
amendment I second it
moved and seconded discussion
representative Muse would you like to
speak to your motion
yeah yes I I think we've we've we've uh
we've had this bill in front of us for
the last three sessions and as
representative janvin said uh this is
something that's important to the people
of Hampton uh these issues are important
to a lot of people uh whenever we can't
go back in history and correct an
injustice but what we can do is we can
acknowledge that uh an injustice took
place we can't correct the Injustice but
what we can do is we can correct the
record and that's really what we're
attempting to do uh with this bill this
was an important bill to other
representatives in Hampton one was the
former chair of this committee uh it was
one of the uh the last bills that he
Prime sponsored in the last session uh
so uh hopefully we can uh we can we can
get this thing through and I and I thank
the chair uh for all of his efforts
behind the scenes uh to make this happen
thank you
thank you representative Jammer would
you like to speak to your motion a
second
I'm sorry representative gathway would
you like to speak to you a second
thank you I would um I would add that I
was very careful with this and I went to
House Council and we contemplated
contact in the Supreme Court to make
sure that we weren't violating any
separation of powers issues
um the the statutes in the Constitution
reserves certain rights to the courts
and to the executive branch with as far
as Pardons and things of that nature
what this is doing is this is saying as
a body we do not agree with what was
done and we feel that this should be
corrected at least historically so that
we can go on the record of saying that
these were wrong these things were wrong
it does not have a legal binding effect
as if uh pardon were issued but
the voice of the legislature is going to
speak on it any further comments or
no okay I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll
motion is otpa vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative pru yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
representative Bolton
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative nunning Wong yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
gerbilts yes motion passes 20-0
motion passes 20-0 it will go on consent
Mr chairman I I would like to have this
on regular calendar so we can speak
speak to the bill on the house floor
okay it will go on the regular Calendar
please make a note Lieutenant Clerk and
I like to think that the honorable
Ronnie Cushing is somewhere better right
now looking down on us smiling
and with that I will close the executive
session on HP 89
and open to the executive session on HP
and I recognize representative Rhodes
for a motion thank you Mr chair
um I make a motion of itl for House Bill
moved by representative Rhodes second
and by representative pru
motion is an expedient to legislate uh
representative Rhodes would you like to
speak to your motion
uh thank you Mr chair
um
we heard a lot of testimony on on this
particular bill
and all the fishermen that were here
you know it it was almost like if they
were
if it was trying to make a wrong for
them when they didn't feel that they had
had been wronged in any way
um it was said how they actually
appreciate the support that they get
from fish and game
um additionally it you know fish the the
job the fishing game have this this
would quite literally be putting the
handcuffs on them and considering that
these are not emergencies whenever
they're they're doing their job
that would be it would take hours if not
days in order to get the search warrant
um the site of fish and game alone
does actually
um entice better behavior and all the
way around I could go on and on because
I have three pages of it but at the end
of the day everybody that was here
did did not want this to pass for the
record except for the sponsor that's
true story representative gathroy or no
exception isn't true would you like to
speak to your motion
sure I I agree with the co-chair that uh
in the focus of their fishing game
duties
um getting a warrant would be
very cumbersome
and they do their job very well when
they switch into motor vehicle stops or
anything else they understand that
all those regular rules uh of search and
seizure apply to them and they would get
the warrants so I don't see any need to
be changing anything that's been working
very well
thank you I'll open discussion by saying
I I took the concerns of the Prime
sponsor very seriously I looked at the
statutes if it were the case that fish
and game could go on the roads and start
enforcing motor vehicle violations and
search vehicles and persons that had
nothing to do with their fish and game
activities without warrant I would
certainly be in favor of this but I
spoke to the house Council I asked the
Attorney General's office and the Fish
and Game all of them seem to be of the
same mind that that was not the case and
could not provide a case an actual case
where this happened if such a case
exists in the future I would be happy to
entertain this bill again but at the
this point it does not seem necessary
their their waiver
from having to get a search warrant is
indeed the definition of exes and
circumstances because every time they
are somewhere where they have to enforce
this law it is exigent because well
frankly no one's going to live in the
woods and wait for them to get a search
warrant or on the water
um and I would open it up for any
further comments or discussion anyone
else
representative Bolden
I was impacted by the discussion during
the
um public hearing about
the concept that you waive certain
rights when you apply for a license and
I appreciated hearing about that
and the aspect that it's communal
property and
um that that's the purpose of uh
licensing and the regulation
that's all thanks thank you that and
that that makes perfect sense
um anyone else
see none of us to clerk to Colorado and
the motion is in expedient to legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolton
yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative nanang Wang yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
CE yes motion passes 19-1
representative Cameron do you reject to
consent
I do not and it will not be a Minority
Report and it is on consent uh the
motion itl passes I close the public
Hearing in house bill 498. I opened a
public hearing on HP four excuse me five
four five
excuse me executive session thank you
representative scitec and I recognize
representative Rhodes to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl for
house bill 545.
second
representative Murphy seconds yes
representative Rhodes would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would thank
you Mr chairman
when a sponsor comes and presents a bill
you take them for you take them at their
word that what their intentions are and
and what you know what they look to
achieve with with the bill
and I have tried very hard to figure out
exactly what the intention was with this
particular Bill and I'm I'm not really
sure to be honest with you I do know
that the the people that work for the
the New Hampshire Coalition
um against domestic violence and sexual
assault
that becomes their lives and they lose
sleep at night over some of the horror
stories that they hear they have worked
diligently to
continue the the progress and to go
backwards with changing some of the
protections have been put into place is
is awful
and directly from a printout that we got
it victims should never be responsible
for the crimes committed against them
nor is it the victim's job to impose the
bill conditions or determine the
resolutions that or the restitution I'm
sorry that that that that says it all
um additionally if you can start to
pay off your victims so that they will
drop their charges we're really going
backwards now and
you know was also stated that oh I I
believe that these people they have tons
of support and they have all these
Advocates that's that's not true it is
it is not easy for the victims of any of
these crimes and a lot of times the
person that is assigned to help them
works for the court they work for the
DA's office to kind of be the liaison in
a stopping point between that victim and
the actual
um attorney the kind of you know help
field some of those calls not
necessarily to advocate for them
and um it's also important to remember
that the victim of these crimes
they are the state's witness they don't
they don't just have protections they
they are there to assist but it is not
their it's not necessarily against them
um I I could go on and on but I don't
think I need to
got to
Q representative representative Murphy
would you like to speak to you a second
yes I would thank you Mr chair
um I strongly support an itl of uh of
this bill although
um as it's presented it's it's you know
amending the victim's Bill of Rights it
quite honestly does the opposite
um given that about half of all murder
cases are domestic violence cases and 80
of DV cases would be dismissed if HB 545
passes
um it sets the stage for victim and
witness intimidation
um and given that the state has the duty
to protect Society at large from the
defendant's behavior I strongly support
an itl
discussion
representative Newell
um I would just like to say having
um worked with many people
um who have been victims of domestic
violence I think that unfortunately what
this bill would do is that it would kind
of exploit
um the the
I'm trying to think of a better word
than to tell you exploit the the state
of mind that people are put in when
they're victims of domestic violence and
it would basically weaponize that
against them or has the potential to
weaponize that against
um them so yeah I'm voting idea
thank you further discussion
seeing nonetheless to call the rule the
motion is an expedient to legislate
nice chair Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec
representative pru yes
representative Jan Fran
absolutely representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzai yes
representative Harry gathright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy
yes
representative Newman
the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative naning Wong yes
representative wheeler aye chairman Roy
chair votes yes motion passes 2-0
the motion of inexpeding to legislate
passes 20 to nothing any ejection
consent hearing none they'll be on
consent I hereby close the executive
session on HB 545 I hereby open the
executive session on House Bill 581 and
I recognize representative Reed for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I vote uh House Bill
581 itl
is there a second second second by
representative Manion
representative Bree would you like to
speak to your motion thank you yes
um the controlled Drug Act was
instituted in um in 1970 with amendments
made throughout the years
um it has served as a good guide for
medical professionals
um and law as well and I feel that at
this time
um to repeal that even for with a study
committee is premature and with our drug
um
problem we're facing it I don't think
there's any benefit to this maybe we can
revisit in a few years when drug laws
regarding marijuana change we can
revisit it then but right now
I moved to itl this bill
thank you representative Manuel would
you like to speak to you second no
thanks
I would um I'll start the discussion
um
I think that folks that support
marijuana legalization need to be very
careful of these bills right now the
federal government
it's kind of turned in a blind eye to
some of the states that are selling and
allowing marijuana for even medical use
currently it is still illegal federally
and at any point that could change in
the federal government could decide to
come in and shut everything down and
arrest everyone involved in the
production distribution selling medical
marijuana cards or not
until such time as the federal
government changes these laws
continuing to flout them by trying to
legalize all kinds of different drugs at
the same time is going to get the
attention you don't want and it's going
to bring the enforcement hammer down we
need to move our federal delegates to
change the laws at that level
before we continue
to pass legalization bills at the state
level that are just going to bring
negative attention to the populace of
the state and some people who rely on
medical marijuana for their medical
conditions will suffer
further discussion representative Newell
um just to say quickly agree
um also
I am completely for decriminalization
and legalization
um I do feel like it needs to be done in
a specific way it needs to be done in a
in a responsible way starting with what
you said as well
um and you know there needs to be Sports
there needs to be regulation around it I
just feel uh very strongly about
um not being illegal but it being legal
in the right way so that people are
protected and using responsibly and the
least harm
representative wheeler with respect to
representative Reed the chairman and
representative Newell I do disagree with
the itl motion seeing as though the
controlled Drug Act was passed in 1971
and to paraphrase what the assistant uh
to the assistant to the president for
domestic affairs said uh when asked
about the controlled Drug Act it was we
couldn't illegalize being against the
war or being black so we had to
illegalize being we had to illegalize
cannabis for the hippies and heroin for
the blacks and criminalize them as much
as possible and seeing as though that
was the intent for the controlled Drug
Act when it was passed they didn't think
too much into it there wasn't the
necessarily regulations to make sure it
was safe and a cogent policy they just
implemented it to stop uh discussion on
the war in Vietnam and uh organizing
that was going on in the black
communities I think repealing a law
which was so egregiously passed would be
beneficial for the New Hampshire state
government and I think the harms that
you illustrate would be worthwhile
because sometimes there has to be some
negative conversations to get to to
where you want to go in terms of
repealing doing something so egregious
so I'll be voting against the itl motion
thank you and I respect your opinion and
who knows which one of us is right but
until we get the feds to fix it we're
really just spinning our Wheels any
further discussion see now the last
clerk to call the roll
motion is inexpeding to legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion yeah
representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes
representative Harry goth right yes
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman no
the clerk votes now representative
Newell yes
representative nothing Wong yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy Gerald yes
motion passes 17-3
I'm representative wheeler where you'll
be doing the um the report on this you
should be on all the drug bills I guess
no I'm just I will be I'm willing to do
The Minority Report on this absolutely
you you do want to uh you don't want it
on consent correct
okay thank you
with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 581 the motion of
inexped into legislate passed
I will open the executive session on
House Bill 191 and I'll recognize
representative Stone to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to itl Bill 191 this bill if
passed
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion yes sir I would
this bill if passed would add an
additional burden on state agencies to
include State Police and Judiciary there
are currently other viable options for
legitimate Firearms disposal that comply
with both state and federal law
representative would you like to speak
to you second what he said
thank you
um
I really this this one was
this one was a little confusing
um I think they can be destroyed now if
they want to they seem to have a process
in place the state police didn't seem to
didn't seem to they didn't take a side
on it but they they didn't they did
point out that it would um it could be
costly
so
any other discussion
could the clerk please call the roll
when she gets a second
motion is itl represent uh Vice chair
Rhodes yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
Jan fan yes representative Manion yes
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy no
representative Newman no
the clerk votes yes
representative Newell no
representative naning Wong yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
triplets yes motion passes 16-4
motion of being experienced to legislate
passes 16-4 hereby close the executive
session House Bill 191
um who's doing the report on that one
representative stone is doing that what
about the no report
s
if one day some point thank you
um
open the executive session house bill
305.
and I recognize representative
roads to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl for
House Bill 191
I'm sorry my bad 305.
and invite TL for hospital 305. and your
second was the 305 correct okay
um would you like to speak to you a
second
your motion
I I would gladly yield if somebody else
can explain exactly what was happening
here
okay representative Peru you want to
take a crack at it uh I don't think this
is the right time for this bill it kind
of muddies the water uh
working with the feds and when they can
and when they can't and
I just don't see a need at the moment
I'm good
representative tensar did you want to
talk about this uh I'm in agreement with
this I just think that there was some
confusion amongst the committee as to
representative mania's testimony I would
request that we have a subcommittee on
this to get more information out of it
very pretty I am
you know I I'm inclined to agree I I
don't think we really understood what
the heck just happened
um so I I would like to um I'd like to
I'm gonna go ahead and take that advice
and uh I'll withdraw my second if um
representative
I wouldn't I would I I'll withdraw it
thank you in fact don't
having said that okay the motions have
been withdrawn the it is open for
further motions at this point I'm going
to appoint a subcommittee and we are
going to take a quick look at that I'd
like a one-week turnaround if I could uh
representative tensor you're the chair
um anyone else want to get on this
representative Stone
no you're not you want to be on it
anyone
wow
represent Manion I'd like some folks
from the other side we've all Blended so
close now that I can't tell the
difference
now representative
representative wheeler thank you for
volunteering my seat mate here that's
fine you're like you're like the drugs
and guns and representative uh
representative Reed would you would you
mind representative Reed you're laughing
but yeah would you mind representative
Reed rounding that out please
yeah it's not funny anymore
representative Reed
um okay with that we will take this back
up next week after the subcommittee gets
us some more information so we can
understand it I hereby
um recess the public hearing
executive session yeah
okay
um represent I am recessing the public
hearing on House Bill 305
and that concludes our business
representative scitec would like to be
recognized for Mark before we LV
kid here we can't hear you get here
uh I listened to representative
Wheeler's uh statements about the origin
of the controlled Drug Act and its
motivation I hope he's not right
I'd be happy to show you the quote
afterwards Mr site oh well sure you're
right it's just sad that that's how it
came about it is very sad absolutely but
we have an opportunity to reasonably
change it hopefully
thank you